being off the boat here we are finally
docked in Jamaica
I see stuff for Antonius it against
armies NEC nice view
you didn't actually have any idea what
we're going to be
balls over there that was climbing
here they go
getting through the hardest part look
ahead exudate connected a CVS and we
exit I want access
it's far on the excursion
there's one more to go and I think I'm
gonna peace out because there was love
I will offer you guys I'm done
this is the waterfall early
I'm done I didn't want to ruin my camera
we just completed done
official size
I don't know how we made it thank you
for saving get some with our waterfall
excursion what you guys think is fun no
we don't fit be on land to get what
we're landing on that one in the
waterfall
time to bobsled it's not gonna jump on
me walk spider where is it right there
above the rain forest here in Jamaica
are you scared too close to the line
somebody lose their sandals
those are [__] oh we're stuck why are we
not moving
we're not moving right now this is so
far down look how pretty that is
oh my god this is unbelievable
I'm a little scared not alive I'd like
demography go
Oh
oh my goodness
why Scott we're gonna fly right off his
Trek oh I'm crying right now
I know tears just came out I really I
know I thought we were gonna die like
there is no doubt about it at the death
we were flying off this track oh my
goodness that was so much fun oh my gosh
I recommend it it was so fast
really I seriously thought we're fine
get something out so slow let's go back
down the wood
go chairlift
I got jealous skylift shreddin
bobsledding and it's quite an adventure
finally almost off the chairlift
honestly this is been the longest ride
of my life I think yes I'm pretty long
good thing ever that's snap just laying
here on the beach in Jamaica your
Margaritaville margaritas are actually
quite tasty good alive there's the boat
over there
they're yelling about
oh so slow
this point and yeah I should not allowed
to do that
not gonna buy
do not want to buy it that no I don't
have I won twice three times don't want
to buy it
jig matchups here on the boat
about all these
her drop the damn squares
a lot
yeah
okay here's today's animal little baby
bunny and little baby bonding you or
make him dance look at the eyes like
honestly I can't believe people spend
time just making this you see a good
picture